allora mi togliero questo e voi farete
finta di essere sorpresi perché voi
sapete come sono adesso quindi inutile
questa volta stiamo facendo però per
l'audience
va bene va bene tanto è tutto falso su
youtube ciao a tutti ragazzi benvenuti
in questo nuovo video dove ho invitati
amici a casa mia sto indossando una
mascherina semplicemente per il fatto
che loro non sanno
compresa
amo madonna perché interamente la
recitazione 0 recitazione 0 ok va bene
una cosa ma da quale film degli anni 90
dottor strange esattamente del e di
quello che fa si compiace i miei istinti
animaleschi comunque allora il discorso
è che ho preparato una serie di commenti
se noi guardiamo effettivamente la
reazione della gente io voglio
commentare questa cosa perché molti
hanno avuto una reazione un po disparata
o disperata nel senso che molti hanno
detto incredibile tieniteli molti hanno
detto fai schifo e quindi c'è questo 50
50 che quel che sembri uscito da un film
per adulti negli anni 90 però ma è un
complimento per me sento ti vedremo mai
un complimento la trattativa
partiamo commento number one dove
sicuramente to creek e figurative barba
si è visto tra azzurri e gabini questa
cosa ok e volevo chiedervi se avere un
minimo di chissà che cosa mi cambia i
16bit viene unita di cui io non so che
sto 2020 e più di sorpreso adesso se
riusciamo a parte questa abbastanza easy
nei sensi volevo farla volevo farla
vedere a fine dicembre cioè finirebbe
per chiudere 2020
poi detto va beh no dai che poi un
casino ok allora sono iniziate le perché
quando tu hai la barba tu sei tutti 6
jack sparrow sia giusto torta lista di
marco merinos tipo loro mazzini tipo di
tutti i sei istituti indicano la barba 6
che sono anche io mi sono anche giovani
bar corri a marco berlino marco berlino
con
la sua arma ma tu sei tutti con la barba
però ed è in questi momenti che capisci
che stai invece mi ha mai sofferto tanto
in effetti nella mia vita nonostante io
abbia di più tardi
io credo la via avuto field of dawn che
le tecniche ho avuto non ho avuto più
lata una relazione che va beh questo non
penso anche tutti gli apparati
comunque a parte questo io non so se lui
l'ha scritto perché sembro più vecchio
perché lui mi vede più vecchio giocabili
show esatto perché lui capisce capita la
sua mente è cresciuto con terna è finita
la sua e vai a lavorare noi dove la napa
noi lavora non pare gli influencer che
non servono a niente
mi dissocio morante libri e il peso
della peluria ho fatto veramente lavando
tigre sono i baffi tu senti il peso dei
baffi quando non hai mai voti baffino ti
giuro a perché tu non ce li hai
sinceramente secondo me sei un film mi
sembra iva rapidità italiano poi nun te
preoccupà da barba the crash dopo anche
non dove anche dove non e questa cosa mi
spaventa perché mi fa ridere
philippa italiano solo perché ho la
barba del suo certo c'è sempre un motivo
per copiare pd by un pesante limite mi
sempre molto per copiare che si sono mai
cambiato la barbati pesce dopo anche
dove non dovrebbe
io non l'ho capito che il tempo c'è il
tocco in più cosa significa dei fattacci
nadal ci insegna ma nessuno ha scritto
di un altro strangers no comunque se ci
passivamente il dottor se c'è quello che
facciamo vedere come l'ho fatta vedere
relativa cioè per me questa è veramente
figo perché sembra veramente questo cioè
non sembra lui troppo però un po da
lontano deciso miei qui adesso nell'auto
linee giulia la barba si paghiamo un
altro 20 negli studi di animazione
prodigio armamenti sopra tipo png così
che si sta già come lo faccio subito
jump io non lo fermi giuro su dio già
prendi la mia auto è tutta la mia auto
devi devi farle seguire con la barba per
favore non lo fare magari adesso
no fermo fobico schizzinoso ma amico di
merd marco merino incoerente che è stata
mi ha fatto ridere basso effettivamente
è vero una volta dormito nel suo letto
no no no è un sacco di live dove la
parte le jam piazzato elevati qui per i
pubblici dal viso va bene giampiero cosa
ecco dove ho già visto questi beni
pubblici
si no mamma olio john week
abbiamo già jokic a casa amica a casa un
sacco bellissimo draga ora mi dovete
spiegare come fa ad avere così seguito
così seguiti ma ok magari può essere
simpatico ma livello di tendenza come fa
interessarvi la barba di un'altra
persona anche essendo famosa non riesco
a capire cosa ci sia di tanto
interessante ma dove generazione è
fallita poi ad avere ad hal apostrofa
senti non so che dirti tranne che mi
stabilito contatore dei video se non
sbaglio si chiama simone ei ragazzi che
si erano i commenti della community su
come ha reagito la mia barba è questione
commenti falsi dei miei amici su come
hanno reagito alla barba che ha agito
quindi fa niente
vi ringrazio di dei commenti per esso
store esistendo vediamo quanto la
portiamo avanti questa cosa ho tagliato
le isole che adesso andiamo non fa parte
cambiato poi tagliarla si muovano ci
rivediamo ad un prossimo mio un bacino a
tutti
dalla mia barba non cresce
[Musica]
ma